hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex legends again
and as I stated in my last video I was
correct there is a lore video for Watson
also known as Natalie Paquette we're
gonna be talking about her in just a few
moments I was always like to be if you
do enjoy a subscriber if we knew I
covered the lore of Apex legends and as
well as the news of apex legends to keep
everyone up to date on what's happening
within the story and just within
gameplay in general so if that sounds
good definitely consider subscribing my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and with that
let's get started with today's lore
video so Watson's real name is Natalie
Paquette she is 22 years old her
homeworld is in solace her tactical
ability is called the perimeter security
passive is called the spark of genius
and the ultimate is called the
interception pylon now she's considered
the static defender and natalie is
actually a familiar face within the apex
games though for a different reason than
most of the legends she's actually
daughter of the game's lead electrical
engineer
she studied his manuals to stay close to
him and discovered her calling at a very
young age though she could be completely
distracted one moment and then
hyper-focused the next electricity
grounded her it's ordered predictable
flow made sense in a way that the rest
of the world did it for her she devoured
every type of book she could on the
subject and eventually became such a
skilled engineer that she commissioned
to build the apex game's modified
containment ring or also as the ring or
storm as some people call in game but
unfortunately her father died the day it
was revealed during the match leaving
her alone and helpless at her lowest
moment a group of competitors invited
her to return to the arena with them
assuring her that she would always have
a home with them inside the apex games
she now fights alongside her friends in
the arena she helped build destroying
incoming missiles recharging shields
creating fences and using her pylon to
silence fights that get too loud no one
knows the arena better than Watson and
anyone who underestimates her is in for
a shock and good time that was basically
the brief history of Watson but there is
a few other things I want to talk about
we're gonna go over her abilities real
quick what the name is and won't they
entail as well as a little note that her
father gave her before she passed away
so first up is her attack the
gullibility it's called the perimeter
security you basically connect nodes to
create electrical fences that damage and
slow enemies her passive ability is
called the spark of genius ultimate
accelerants fully recharge your ultimate
ability in standing new
interception pylon also boosts your
tactical ability and with the
interception pylon the ultimate ability
it's a electrified pylon that destroys
incoming ordnance and repairs damaged
seals as long as it stands and you can
put up a max of three throughout the map
at one time and throughout this trailer
she was reading a letter that her father
did give her so I'm gonna be reading
that out real quick right now my dearest
Natalie as I write this letter it's the
middle of the night in late summer
although to be fair it's always summer
in solace is it not you've poked your
head out of the bedroom twice already
insisting I retire for the night always
looking out for me though you're still a
child to yourself at least that's what I
pretend but it appears that may no
longer be the case an hour ago you
cracked the equations necessary to power
the force field you showed me up tonight
my magnificent daughter and I couldn't
be happier or proud of you for that I
always knew you were special but I never
did fathom that the little girl who
taught her stuffed Nessie doll
multiplication tables when she was six
what a girl to master quantum laser
mechanics I talked to Jacob but the
syndicate and assured him that the
modified containment forcefield will be
operational in a month's time the games
are ago and it's all thanks to you but I
do owe you an apology
I'm just a doddering old fool trying to
hold on to my baby a little while longer
before he loses her to adulthood but I
do see you I'm sorry it's taken this
long but I now see the strong brilliant
wonderful young woman you've become
and I know when the day comes that I'm
no longer wait walking these dusty old
streets you're going to be just fine
hold on to this feeling Natalie savor
this victory summer may be eternal on
solace but the world can be a very cold
place at times and those days when I'm
no longer with you and feel alone and
frustrated that there are too many
mountains to climb
please reread this letter remember that
you are my little girl and because of
you my darling daughter the people of
the Outlands will have reason to smile
soon enough the games will be brilliant
because you are brilliant my daughter
can and will do anything she wants in
this life because my daughter is the
smartest woman in the frontier I love
you with all my heart forever papa
and PS The Syndicate does agree with you
the ring is a hell of a lot better name
than the force field so you went on this
bet for now but yeah that was the little
letter that her father wrote for Watson
I was tearing up a little bit trying to
[ __ ] read that goddamn such a
heartful letter that he wrote there but
this is of course I believe a couple
days are probably a week or two before
the force
field was released or the ring was
released to the apex games because of
course he's dying maybe of some illness
or just old age and he did pass away the
day that it was revealed so she likes to
keep this letter with her while riding
in the apex games that she can always be
remembered of her father and then prove
him right and always just be her shining
little daughter that she's always been
to him be a going-over the little bit of
the trailer and what it breaks down of
the little story of the Outlands that
she has as you can tell there's just a
lot of electrical parts moving a lot of
pylons moving now I'm not any electrical
engineer I don't do any of that [ __ ] so
I don't know what the actual term would
be called but it looks like a lot of
pylons moving electricity currents
throughout the pylons and connecting -
I'm assuming - this big-ass beam which
is most likely going to generate the
ring there's also a little quick picture
of them in some kind of cartoon form of
the dad on the right and her on the left
they're looking at I believe the Kings
Canyon I believe there's another picture
of what that looks like if it was drawn
by an artist this was on their
screenshots page which of course is the
thumbnail for this video because it
looks absolutely insane love to see it
and then a little bit later you can see
that she actually has the photo of her
dad with her and of course the letter
that she carries always with her in the
apex game seeing as her dad passed away
and she still wants to remember him even
though he has long been gone now here's
a little bit of lore of where she grew
up like I told you she grew up on solace
and that is actually a planet within the
solar system of where titanfall takes
place in the universe and it is a planet
on the frontier and it is also home to
Gibraltar and mirages and the namesake
for the Epis search-and-rescue
Association of solace which I do believe
Gibraltar was a part of because I'd know
he was some type of search-and-rescue
person before coming to the apex games
and the frontier is basically this huge
planetary system that has a bunch of
other planets within it it can take days
to weeks to travel to these multiple
planets most people don't really go here
they like to stay within the core
systems which is a lot closer to Earth
but for anybody that's a pioneer
Explorer mercenary outlaw or soldier the
frontier can provide a lot of adventure
and opportunity for those such people
and those places can include the
Freeport system the Badlands the Dakota
System the Demeter system the unknown
system sector Bravo - one yuuma system
and the Outlands and of course as you
guys know the Outlands is also part of
king's canyon which of course is the
place where the apex games
located so yes this place is of course
located within the frontier so it would
be completely obvious she's basically
right next to Kings Canyon so she of
course is gonna work for the apex games
just makes a whole lot of sense there
one thing I also noticed during the
letter is that they talked about a
company called syndicate sadly we have
no idea who they are
even in titanfall 1 & 2 or any other
adaptation of the game there really is
nothing about the syndicate they're a
new type of company I'm assuming just
based off of how this letter was written
they work ascend decay commissioned the
father and Watson to basically make the
ring so I'm assuming these guys are some
type of management company probably for
the apex games they could be led by
BLISK the guy who owns the apex games
and created it so this could be just as
management company a company he's a part
of or maybe something bigger entirely
them you know they some companies have a
sinister side to them that some people
don't understand
so that could totally be it for this
company but the developers did say that
they do want to add a lot more stories
to this to this game so I'm assuming
we'll know a lot more about syndicate
whether with a new hero who is part of
the syndicate coming in the next couple
seasons or so or just some type of other
story that we get to see from these guys
and I'd love to know who these syndicate
guys are and kind of what their whole
motive is yeah that was the whole lore
of Watson I just wanted to give you guys
a brief description of where she is you
know and solace or how she even got here
and basically the story of this hero and
just everything about her and what makes
her so unique
first if you guys want me to do more
lore videos in the future I love to do
more of these these are so much fun to
look up yeah guys like to be if you do
enjoy let me know your thoughts on
Watson in the comments below I think
she's gonna be a really fun hero let me
know what you think about her story I
think it's really interesting and
probably one of the better ones of the
characters and apex legends subscriber
for new I covered the informational side
of apex legends that being the balance
changes to here updates the patch notes
and leaks so if we want to be kept up
with the story or the gameplay of apex
legends definitely stay subscribe to the
channel my Twitter and discord will be
in the description down below and my two
most recent videos are gonna be popping
up on the screen if you guys do want to
check that out and with that guys hope
you have a great stir day thank you for
watching the video and peace out enjoy
the rest of your day
you
[Music]